all right so normally we would go to an
interview now but we actually had a
last-minute interview cancellation that
was completely beyond our control so I
thought why don't we go to the phones
and see what's on people's minds not
something we usually do on Wednesday
show but let's do it six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty s the
number listened for your area code
because you won't hear like a beep when
I put you on so listen for your area
code first callers from the 404 area
code 404 caller tell us who this is and
what's on your mind all right David this
is Jeff from Atlanta how you doing good
go ahead Jeff good good I was just
calling to see uh ask you a couple
questions about your progressive
policies if you were in favor of
Medicare for all $15 minimum wage and in
the Lord's that sort of thing I've seen
a lot of your videos and I'm just trying
to nail down where you stand on those
issues yeah I've been pretty clear about
all those issues I'm for a system of
health care where everybody gets at
least a basic level of care regardless
of ability to pay I think health care
should be taken health insurance should
be taken out of the so-called free
market or profit market I have not been
definitive about whether 15 is the exact
right minimum wage but I do think it
needs to be closer to a living wage what
other questions did you have if you
support the ending all the
interventionist wars in Iraq Yemen
Afghanistan just because we're creating
more terrorists that way as well yep I
mean generally speaking I'm not an
isolationist but I don't believe that
the United States should be or
necessarily even has the right to be the
world's police officer well absolutely
because I mean if you look at before the
Obama administration we were in two
conflicts and after the Obama
administration were involved in seven
and now Trump is ramp that up to almost
ten with you that can also be deceptive
also I mean you got a it's important to
talk about the degrees to which we're
involved in those conflicts but I
understand what you're saying yeah
absolutely absolutely I just fine I just
I just feel that there isn't any public
voices
on the mainstream media talk about these
issues and that's why I constantly keep
bringing them up with others and yeah
and there's because everyone's still
focused on irrelevant issues like who
won the election and why they won the
election instead of moving forward and
say hey you know Democrats you need to
focus on progressive policies and not
just be an anti-trump I agree with you I
agree with you particularly because you
don't know what will ultimately come of
the Trump Russia investigation you've
got to have something to run on you've
got to be able to make a case in 2018
Jeff I appreciate the call thank you so
much thank you appreciate it every now
and then you got to tout your
progressive credentials and I'm glad
that Jeff gave you the opportunity to do
so yes it really teed a few up for me
there I like that